series on the Washington journal
throughout the month of June we're going
to look at some media mogul some media
business leaders we're going to start
off today with William Randolph Hearst
next week we'll be looking at Henry Luce
and further on down the road William
Paley and Ted Turner the David Nassau is
the author of this book the chief the
life of William Randolph Hearst he joins
us from New York City this morning good
morning mr. Nassau good morning let's
start simply who was William Randolph
Hearst William Randolph Hearst was the
son of a 49er miner who became a
millionaire and one of the world one of
the country's first women
philanthropists and he began as a
newspaper publisher and by the 30s was
the most important media magnate media
mogul in the world he owned newspapers
magazines newsreel stations a movie
studio radio stations a little radio
network and much much more and it was he
the first American media mogul I think
he's the first yeah if media mogul means
if you know if we look at what the word
means media is a communications medium
you know mediums put their hands on the
table and communicate to the living from
the dead
well media is that communications medium
it's that interface between where
messages coming from the people who are
going to get it and what Hearst did was
Hurst understood right away that once he
had gathered the news once he had
written his editorials once he had his
opinions it made no sense to confine it
just to newspapers why not put that same
news in those same opinions on the radio
in newsreels in magazines so in moving
out from newspapers to these other media
I think it's fair to say he's the first
media mogul what did he own cash he
owned newspapers and major major
newspapers in New York Los Angeles San
Francisco's Chicago
burg Boston every major city in the
United States except Philadelphia he
made a deal early with Adolph Ochs the
New York Times who wanted to move to
Philadelphia
he owned major magazines all over the
world including cosmopolitan which was
the most important opinion Journal he
owned his own newsreel service he had a
radio network he had his own news
service that competed with the AP and
the UPI he had a feature service he had
a couple of syndicate services and he
owns his own movie studio which was a
very cosmopolitan cosmopolitan studios
which was in the beginning of the 20th
century a major major producer of motion
pictures one of the pictures you have in
your book is of William Wirt Randolph
Hearst in 1919 greeting the American
soldiers coming back he's standing amid
several politicians did politicians fear
or did they want his endorsement did he
endorse this is a very interesting
picture Hearst was opposed to World War
one and when the Americans entered World
War one he sort of tepidly approved but
argued for a peace treaty from the very
beginning to the very end you see here
when it was announced that he was going
to greet the soldiers there was all
sorts of hubbub there were letters
congressional reports congressional
inquiries all of which said that this
man should not be allowed to greet the
soldiers he snuck in there at the last
minute so that picture was taken he was
feared he was not loved he was feared by
politicians because he spoke directly to
millions and millions of Americans in
the at the height of his career in the
20s and the 30s one out of every five
Americans read a Hearst newspaper
the numbers are on the screen 2:02 is
the area code for all of our numbers if
you want to join our conversation with
david nassau the author of the chief
talking about William Randolph Hearst
five eight five three eight eight zero
if you're a Republican 585 three eight
eight one four Democrats five eight five
three eight eight two four all others
and of course our international line
five eight five three eight eight three
mr. Nassau you said that politicians
feared William Randolph Hearst how did
he influence politics and public policy
he was I got interested in Hearst
from the very beginning because I wanted
to write about the media and politics
and the most interesting way to do that
was to take a man who was a
multi-millionaire who was a media mogul
and wanted to use and was willing to use
all of his power to get himself elected
president never got himself elected
president got pretty close in 1904 he
came in second in the balloting for the
Democratic at the Democratic convention
never got himself elected president
though he served two terms in Congress
but he set the agenda when he took up an
issue whether it was the World Court
whether it was the income tax that issue
became a major issue and every
politician had to take a stand on that
issue okay I'm sorry go ahead
no that's that's fine uh you mentioned
the World Court and the income tax issue
what were his positions he was a West
Coast isolationist what do I mean by
that I mean that he was absolutely
opposed to American intervention in or
American involvement in the affairs in
Europe he believed that Europe was the
old world Europe was dying Europe was
engaged in this civil war in that
resulted in the Great War in World War
two and that America was the new world
it had to keep out he was not an
isolationist however when it came to
Mexico to Panama to South America to the
Philippines obviously or to the Pacific
he wanted he thought that's where
America
interest lay and that's where we should
be putting our energies he was
absolutely opposed to the World Court
he was absolutely opposed to the League
of Nations he was absolutely opposed to
the First World War and the Second World
War he did not want American boys to die
he did not want American dollars spent
propping up England in a war for
supremacy in Europe you say he was
against World War two also did that hurt
him in readership he quickly came around
by the time World War Two came around he
was a relatively old man and he had
begun to take a little tall a little bit
from from his newspapers he was smart
enough to know that once war was
declared he was going to be an American
he was going to be a patriot and he was
going to be full square in favor of
prosecuting of prosecuting that war
but he argued throughout in World War
one and in World War two for some sort
of negotiations what hurt him and what
hurt him very badly what nearly bankrupt
his empire and what nearly destroyed him
was when in nineteen mid-1930s he took
on Franklin Roosevelt he had gotten
Roosevelt elected he had supported him
and then after the income tax and after
he began to think that Roosevelt was too
much of an internationalist he went
after him and he went after him
viciously Hearst did not believe in
neutral journalism he believed in
advocacy journalism he wrote his own
editorials and he put him on the front
page and he signed them in big big
letters and then he read those
editorials on the radio and talked him
on his newsreels so if you bought a
Hearst newspaper there was no way to
escape the editorial stance of that
newspaper and when he went after
Roosevelt he alienated many of the lower
middle
as middle-class and working people that
made up the bulk of his circulation
he was so violently anti-ro Savelle anti
New Deal that his readers had to make a
choice Roosevelt or Hearst and more
often than not the choice was Roosevelt
his circulation declined and he got into
terrible trouble in 1937 and in effect
lost his control of his empire for about
five six years until World War two first
call-up for David Nassau author of the
chief Madison Wisconsin Democrat
hi this is so interesting I think I'm
going to try and get that book it sounds
like a fascinating author
I grew up in with very thoughtful
parents who tended to look at both sides
of the question so I'm not sure how much
I was affected by her side just knew he
was really really powerful and people
might have been afraid of him well
recently I'm wondering if you could tell
me if there's any truth about this we
saw the movie the cat's meow directed by
Peter Bogdanovich which is fascinating
and wonderful and I was wondering if
there's any truth to that story no no no
mr. Hassler what is a story she's right
there is absolutely there's absolutely
no truth there has been the movie
director Thomas Ince died shortly after
being on a Hearst yacht in the early
1920s Hearst had a yacht out in
Hollywood he had the yacht and he went
on wonderful cruises and parties on his
yacht on one of those cruises there was
a large group of people including
Hurst's companion Marion Davies Charlie
Chaplin maybe Louella Parsons Thomas
Ince the film director in was taken off
the yacht ill died soon afterwards there
were rumors at the time that Hearst had
somehow shot mistakenly shot in because
he wanted to shoot Chaplin because
Chaplin was in love with Marion Davies
believe me I looked high and low up and
down I did all the research that one
could do to find out if this story was
true there is not a scintilla of
evidence that it's true
none it makes for a great great story I
haven't seen the movie but apparently
it's an enjoyable movie but it has as
far as this historian is concerned
absolutely no truth value next call
Fredericksburg Virginia
good morning yeah good morning uh
actually my question is about the castle
and why exactly was it so luxurious was
he trying to social stature up do one
other person or something um and just
real quick I know that they had a TV
special on the castle and it was hosted
by his granddaughter Patty Hearst and it
was one said that there was uh some
artwork that was never seen to the
public I guess it's down in some
basement or something that is just
unbelievable we would uh basically do
the UH all the museum's throughout the
world all the artwork he collected can
you elaborate on that too great great
question San Simeon is one of the
marvels of the of the world Hurst didn't
much care what other people thought
about him but he wanted to have that he
wanted to live in splendor and luxury
and in beauty and he constructed for
himself that monumental uh castle at San
Simeon which he thought was the most
beautiful place on the earth it's on the
Central Coast of California halfway
between Los Angeles and San Francisco
it is gorgeous if anybody has not seen
it yet it is it is worth a trip all his
life all his life from the time he was a
child
Hearst collected art and he collected
not simply paintings and little pieces
of sculpture he collected monasteries
took him apart stone by stone from Spain
had him shipped to the United States and
put back together again he collected
tapestries he collected huge huge
fireplaces and mantels and sculptures
that weighed in the tons there was no
place to put them all even at San Simeon
so he had where
houses all over the place in Los Angeles
in New York near San Simeon the caller
is absolutely correct
those warehouses especially one in the
Bronx which is still owned by the Hearst
Corporation had all sorts of artworks
and art materials a lot of that was sold
off when in 1937 as I talked about
before
Hearst nearly went into bankruptcy his
art collection was so huge that the
auctioneers and the dealers who were
trying to raise cash to keep his empire
afloat leased an entire floor of Gimbels
fifth floor of Gimbels I believe in
which they began to sell off some of his
smaller knickknacks from the castle and
that had been stored in his warehouses
and never shown to anyone in your book
you have pictures of four other houses
that mr. Hearst owned the castle and
Wales ocean house beacon towers and
Cinderella house how tell us about these
well let me start on the screen you now
see Belmont towers Belmont towers was in
Sands Point Long Island it was
supposedly and and I think this may be
true the model for scott Fitzgerald when
he wrote the Great Gatsby he first
bought this for his wife Millicent
we modeled it with Millicent even though
he had left Millicent and was living
with Marion Davies in California from
Marion Davies he built Ocean House a
100-room beach house in Santa Monica
which was on the water and was the scene
of some of the most glorious parties in
the history of Hollywood in the
Hollywood community
he had an estate in the Central Coast of
California San Simeon he also bought a
13th century castle in Wales st. dönitz
where
visited every summer and this medieval
castle was reconstructed with modern
plumbing modern electricity pools all
the conveniences of home and her spent
two or three weeks there every summer
and until World War Two not finished yet
he also had a an estate called win tune
in Northern California near Mount Shasta
and there instead of building one large
castle as its Saint Simeon as its ends I
mean he had five or six villas this is
one of them each one of them was
specially constructed it looked like a
little bavarian village and he brought
in a man named Pagani who was one of the
great illustrators in Hollywood to draw
murals on the front of each of these and
those murals were half Disney half
Grimm's brothers fairy tales and the
Cinderella house and the bear house and
the other houses were named after the
murals on the front the wind tune estate
is is simply glorious it he also had a
million acre estate in bokura in Mexico
which I don't have a picture at which
was appropriated and taken over by the
by the Mexican government in the 1950s
back to calls next up for David Nassau
Olympia Washington good morning good
morning
my name is Allan Harris I published a
small newspaper in Olympia here this is
the first time I've ever called my eye I
want to say I appreciate c-span this is
I've watched it for years but this is
the first time I called because I was a
publicist of a small newspaper and
William Randolph her is one of my icons
you know
but as as far as objectivity how do you
feel um that William Randolph Hearst
dealt with this you know as far as is
you know Republican Democrat you know
conservative liberal right it's a very
good question very good question horse
did not believe in objectivity he did
not believe that it was possible to be
objective and he didn't think it was the
job of a newspaper to be objective he
believed that it was his responsibility
as a publisher and as a very intelligent
man which he thought he was to tell the
people what he thought what he believed
and he never even attempted to cover all
sides of every question and he never
believed that his readers thought that
he was that was what it was about now we
have to remember that he owned a
newspaper at a moment in time when every
city had multiple newspapers and the
feeling on his part was if you didn't
like what he had to say buy another
newspaper or buy his newspaper and
another newspaper when you read his
newspaper you didn't read a democratic
newspaper or a Republican newspaper you
read a Hearst paper and you were getting
the news as Hearst saw it and editorials
and opinion as Hearst wrote them and
oversaw them he was an advocacy
journalist and up until the 1930s
newspapers in this country were evenly
divided between advocacy journals and
between those journals that practice
what the New York Times called
objectivity all the news that was fit to
print in the late 1920s there is this
wonderful piece in the old Vanity Fair
called The Clash of the Titans and it
asks what is the direction that the
newspapers are going in will it be her
style advocacy personal journalism
that's always exciting that's bombastic
that's passionate that's powerful over
be Adolph Ochs
style journalism that is gray he was the
publisher of the New York Times that's
gray that's a little boring that claims
to be objective
well when Hearst when after Roosevelt
when his opinions
we're so violently out of the mainstream
that he lost circulation it became clear
to newspapers across the country that
gray bland objective journalism which
didn't alienate a large number of
readers was the way to go next called
Pacifica California good morning yes I
wanted to tell Brian lamb that for years
I've relied on c-span for the up-to-date
news and I wonder why you're not
covering present-day moguls instead of
dead ones and I really missed the old
format where we heard more about what's
going on in today's world and I called
earlier to talk on the subject of more
news international news which I'm glad
to hear and only here on PBS N and N
Brian lambs c-span I'm disappointed that
you're going you're trying more to be
History Channel to them informing us
today because we definitely lack media
coverage of international news and
up-to-date news and did you watch the
first two hours of the show this morning
yes I did and I tried dialing through
there good and I should tell you were
going to cover more dead journalists
this afternoon on American writers
walter Lippmann is the focus of this
week's American writers that will be at
3 p.m. live from the Metropolitan Club
here in Washington Montagu New Jersey
Republican good morning yeah how you
doing good my name is John and uh thanks
for letting me come on and I'm a
Republican and conservative and uh you
know just watching what you're showing
about this Democrat that had huge
amounts of money
on big huge houses that I consider what
part contributed to in polluting
environment and all I hear about is how
Republicans are rich and how they are
misers and they're trying to destroy the
world and where I live there's probably
a lot of rich Democrats here and uh you
know it's the same thing the own big
houses they have it all and then they
put down the Republican so the evidence
don't understand David met David Nassau
is a William Randolph Hearst was a
Democrat would he be a Democrat today
no absolutely not we Randolph Hearst was
a radical a populist Democrat in his
youth and then became very much a
Republican he voted for every Republican
from Harding to Hoover turned against
Hoover voted for Roosevelt for one-term
1932 then voted for all the Republicans
again so in the second half of his life
he was very much a Republican he would
have been considered a right-wing
Republican and he would be very much a
Republican today he was violently
opposed to the New Deal
to Roosevelt within two years of
Roosevelt's election what was he close
to any presidents he wasn't he was close
enough to be invited to the White House
by every president from Grover Cleveland
to Roosevelt except for Wilson who he
hated I don't think they I don't think
they liked him very much but they
respected his power and Roosevelt and he
played this dance for years in which
Roosevelt would invite him would give
him gifts would talk about how wonderful
he was the two of them would have a
press conference together and then
Roosevelt would privately attack Hurst
and Hurst would publicly attack
Roosevelt Barry wails good morning I
asked good morning how are you good I
live about 20 miles from st.
on it and it's been it's a beautiful
plate however what I'd like to know is
how do you think Wilma Hearst
actually looked at the international
scene as a whole and how do you think he
would examine today's modern world
compared to after the thirties I think
he would it's it's very difficult I
think he would still be somewhat of an
isolationist very much of an
isolationist I think he believed that it
was not America's business to try to
police the world and it was not
America's business to attempt to fight
terrorism let us say all over the world
or communism all over the world
he believed in protecting America and in
protecting America's interests but he
was very very much an American first er
that is his term really he invents that
term he uses it and he felt very
strongly about it next call for David
Nassau Waterford New York good morning
good morning
first time caller longtime listener
thank you for having bully Randall first
as a subject I'm interested in the
yellow journalism of his style of
newspaper and his relationship with
Harry Anslinger and how he got the
marijuana prohibition started you know I
wish I knew more about that I spent many
many years on Hearst and I did an awful
lot of of research on it a lot of stuff
that goes on in that went on in
California although Hearst took credit
for it it was blamed for it or was
celebrated for it it came out of other
reporters and editors and publishers who
work for the Hearst papers so I
unfortunately was not able to find any
direct connection between Hearst himself
and
the the marijuana restriction movement
next call for David Nassau Columbia
South Carolina Democrat good morning
good morning thank you very much for
c-span I would like to thank you for
having dr. Matthew Brooke Leon recently
on a book notes he's a preeminent
Fitzgerald scholar and we're very proud
of him here in South Carolina and he
made a great interview my questions
about Hurst two points one how did Hurst
relate to the film Citizen Kane in which
he was basically portrayed as a
megalomaniac and kind of following up on
the previous college question
did he use drugs or alcohol thanks very
much and I'll listen to well your
comments let me start with the second
question first he did not use drugs or
alcohol he was he drank very very
occasionally but Hurst and I don't know
how this happened his father was an
alcoholic his children I think drank too
much he is the love of his life Marion
Davies was a terrible alcoholic and he
tried all his life to get her to stop
drinking using every remedy known to you
know to to man and woman and some that
would that were not known but he himself
decided when he was in college and he
wrote a letter to his mother Phoebe
Hurst whose picture is now on camera and
he said I'm gonna stop drinking and he
said that in college and and he didn't
drink from from that moment on a Citizen
Kane great story
by the time Citizen Kane was produced
Hurst was in his late 70s he had been
through it all he had been called every
name in the book and he didn't care just
did not care what riled up his
supporters and his friends including
Louella Parsons his gossip columnist was
not necessarily the portrayal of Hurst
but it was the portrayal of all the
women around him look at Citizen Kane
again a brilliant movie but one of the
most misogynist films ever made every
woman in it is portrayed as
a you know as a nightmare as a monster
and it was this portrayal of the people
the women who were important to hers
that got the people around Hearst angry
and pushed them to try to destroy the
film Hearst let that happen
but Hearst was much bigger than Orson
Welles and didn't didn't pay much
attention to what Orson Welles was doing
was how many times was he married once
to once he was married once never
married
this was Millicent Hearst who was a
showgirl when he married her was an
independent extraordinary woman a very
strong powerful woman in her own right
who had her own philanthropies in New
York was something of a feminist they
were separated in 1925 they were they
remain close to one another and for the
next 35 years of his life
Hearst lived though did not marry Marion
Davies they lived together in California
and he stayed married to Millicent
he stayed married to Millicent right the
reason he didn't divorce was that there
was an unwritten law among publishers at
that time that you did not talk about
the private life of anybody until that
private life got into the courts and
Hearst knew full well that should he
divorce Millicent to marry Marion Davies
that story his life story Marion's life
story
Millicent's life story and the intimate
details of their lives together
would be on every front page in every
newspaper in the country he did not want
that for anybody he also was worried
that because of community property laws
in California he would have to destroy
his empire in order to settle with
Millicent
Millicent agreed she was happy to remain
mrs. William Randolph Hearst they stayed
married they stayed friendly they stayed
in communication he stayed with
Millicent when he visited New York he
helped her design Belmont towers bought
it for her they raised their children
together
but he lived with Marion Davies in
California Knoxville Tennessee
Republican good morning
Laurel Lynch actually I live in new
Tazewell north of Knoxville first of all
I want to commend the c-span people for
always providing provocative and
intelligent situations like this now
this has been knocked around a lot in
the public mind my question is this sir
you said mr. Hurst was adamantly against
world war one world war two involvement
in Europe he saw that is the old world
we were off to a fresh start but you
indicated he saw an American hegemony
hegemony over the Caribbean and into the
Pacific maybe a logical conclusion to
manifest destiny to what degree do you
think he was actually responsible and in
how much good faith did he act regarding
the Spanish warring Cuba in 1898 it's a
very very good question
Hearst in the if you read your US
history textbooks Hearst is always
mentioned as being responsible in some
way for the Cuban Spanish American War
he was like every other newspaper
publisher at the time with very few
exceptions he strongly strongly believed
that the Americans should intervene in
Cuba to get to Spanish out and to win
independence for the Cubans he believed
that Europe had no business whatsoever
running the affairs of life and of the
peoples of this hemisphere and he wanted
them out so he was strongly in favor of
the war did he bring about the war by
himself no he didn't he didn't the
newspaper publishers had a lot to say
but the decisions were made in
Washington and they were made for a
variety of reasons the situation in Cuba
was a
total disaster a total mess Cuba was an
important trading partner of us for the
sake of the economy there was no way
that we could allow Cuba that supplied
us with a lot of sugar and was a trading
partner to remain in turmoil Long Beach
New York on our independent line good
morning a good morning c-span I see that
someone stole my thunder there but I he
he's the father of yellow journalism
that correct yes and I believe that he
had out like you say he was motivated in
his in his mind to bring about the war
and a war against Spain in Cuba but did
he have any any connection or any
investigation into the main which was
the big shout out that in Havana you
knowa
remember the main another lie they
brought us into a war yeah in the big in
the very beginning Hearst in his
newspaper published all sorts of he and
and everybody else again he's not alone
he left to the conclusion that the main
had been blown up
by the by the Spanish that a bomb had
been attached to it uh to its halt
underneath uh he made a lot of noise
about it and he was not entirely
incorrect as as we now think as
historians now think he the most
important thing about to remember about
Hearst was that he was an extraordinary
self-promoter
an extraordinary self-promoter and when
war broke out Hearst took credit for it
on the front page of every Hearst paper
there were two years they were called on
the top right in the top left there were
little banners and every day they said
how do you like the journals war the
journal was the name of his New York
newspaper so he took credit for the war
he said that he had brought it about
that he was the saber savior of the
Cuban people
a lot of people began to believe it I
don't think it's true what was his first
newspaper his first newspaper was the
San Francisco Examiner which he became
editor and publisher of because his
father owned it his father retired his
father was almost illiterate and became
a senator of the United States I'm not
going to make any comments about the
present senators he was as a senator in
Washington he needed a journal he needed
a way to communicate with his people
back home first to get himself elected
and then to get himself re-elected so he
bought a moribund morning newspaper in
San Francisco and made it into a
slightly less than moribund newspaper
and then needed someone he could trust
to run it he gave that newspaper to his
25 year old son whose only only
journalistic experience had been the
treasurer of the Harvard Lampoon for a
year and a half
everyone thought that there was no
conceivable way that Hearst was going to
make a goal of the San Francisco
Examiner at age 25 without any
experience but he did he made it into
the most important newspaper in San
Francisco and on the west coast then
moved to New York after about eight
years and started up a newspaper there
and who owns it now the San Francisco
Examiner has gone through all sorts of
changes it is now owned independently
the there were two major newspapers in
San Francisco the Chronicle and The
Examiner the Hearst people bought the
Chronicle and sold The Examiner
so the Hearst Corporation today owns the
San Francisco Chronicle write the Hearst
Corporation today owns the paper that
was always the major competitor of the
Hearst paper Washington DC thanks for
holding
marvelous series really interesting I'm
so glad you're doing it a comment and a
question
first of all I want to suggest that you
add a name to your list of locals who
you're covering namely Rupert Murdoch
I think is one of the leading figures
these days and there is a author out
there there's a new book called the
Murdock mission it's a bit of a
hagiography
but I think if we had around c-span we
could bring her to truth with some good
questions I think it'd be very
interesting to to cover that and then a
question for your guest who would you
compare her stew in terms of current
moguls with regard to this
self-promotion and press coverage and
reach and I'll take cancer out here
thank you I would agree with you I I
think the only one to compare them to
right now is Murdock and the only and
the reason I would compare him to
Murdock is that Murdock like Hearst has
this instinctual grasp of what's next in
what's new and he moves on his own
Murdock when Hearst went from newspapers
in the magazines and from newspapers and
magazines into radio and its newsreels
all of his advisors said you're nuts you
don't do that your newspaper publisher
you don't go in that direction when
Murdock began to buy satellites for
satellite transmission of television
programs everybody also said he was nuts
but he knew where the technology was
going and in that sense by moving into
new technologies into new media he's
very much like Hearst was the difference
is that Murdock understands I think from
Hurst's failure that in order to keep
your business going it's best to try to
hide in the background one cannot
imagine Murdock
writing an editorial and putting it on
the front page of the New York Post for
example in New York or any of his other
newspapers or appearing on Fox News and
giving a live editorial he wants to stay
in the background so that his political
opinions personal political opinions do
not get identified wholly in the public
mind with his
operations this is David NASA's book
it's called the chief the life of
William Randolph Hearst our next call
comes from Narragansett Rhode Island
Republican good morning good morning
thanks for taking my phone call the
author is describing
Hearst as a reactionary as an adult
promoter that has a political agenda I
find it intriguing and perhaps the
author can comment on the use the
employment of a Walter Winchell probably
then a pre-warp
and during the war one of the most
liberal anti-nazi a journalist in the
country and and Hearst would just sit
back and watch my windshield do his
thing and roll in the money where was
his politics then yeah it's a great not
a great question
Hearst fought with windshield from the
beginning I was able to in a variety of
places one that one of the reasons I
think that I was able to show how
interesting a character Hearst was was
that I had access to all sorts of
telegrams and letters and correspondence
that nobody else had seen that I was
able to find and be able to use and in
some of those you see the correspondence
between Hearst and windshield Winchell
had an enormous following as a gossip
columnist and when Winchell began to
move into political journalism Hearst
tried to cut him off and many many
columns did not run because Hearst read
them in advance and said this isn't
going to run there was this ongoing
battle between the two of them and
precisely because as the reader says
Winchell was Pro Roosevelt he was a new
dealer and he was in favor of
intervention and and Hearst was not so
they had a long-running battle Hearst
didn't want to fire him didn't want to
muzzle him entirely because he had this
great following on the radio and in the
papers but he did everything he could
and to to move him away from political
journalism back to his gossip column
again next call for David Nassau comes
from Pawtucket Rhode Island good morning
honey I'm not exactly talking about
purse but in general I'm 90 years old
and I remember the Roaring Twenties the
beginning of the 20s the prohibition
come an end
that's after the first world war and I
think most of our troubles today was a
virgin from the 2020s because everything
was moving in all types of quickness and
fantasy and we were disregarding a
religion and not keeping ourselves in
order to contain ourselves caller do you
uh did you read any Hearst Newspapers
well no I didn't no I really didn't
were you aware of who William Randolph
Hearst was back in the 20s and 30s yeah
yeah he was a in the paper but newspaper
business far as I'm concerned Randolph
Hearst and in do you recall dude
remember knowing who he was or hearing
about him yeah I hear the bottom and uh
I didn't know I mean I didn't know
whether his Reap I thought he was
Republican but I don't don't
clarified people Republican Democrats me
I think both of them the same okay
thanks for your call this morning and
we'll move on to Ocean View New Jersey
Democrat good morning yeah hi thanks for
taking my call you touched on the the
income tax and I'm curious where he
actually stood on that and I've also
I've read in the past that are the main
reason that he came out against
marijuana was because he had a large
investment in pulp mills I'm wonder if
there's any truth to that uh on the
marijuana I'd you know again I just
don't know I wish I was able to
I had been able to find evidence about
his relationship to the marijuana
movements in the anti marijuana movement
well Jeff didn't find it David Nassau
you right in here that he was the
largest property owner in New York City
at one time he was the largest property
owner in New York City he was the
largest he had acres and acres and acres
also in in California near the Grand
Canyon all over the world he was you
know an incredible he had tons and tons
of money in in real estate and did a
what were his views on religion going
back to the pot tuck at Rhode Island
collar he was not a religious man he was
not a churchgoer he was respectful of
religion but he was not a man who
believed that it was the critical
element in sustaining morality
Washington DC Republican good morning
good morning you're on the air
yes I would like to comment and also go
wired about the influence that a William
Randolph Hearst had in the Hispanic
American War and when the United States
was interested in purchasing Cuba or an
exciting Cuba to to the mainland and
this didn't work out but William
Randolph first became famous freaking
through these politicians in Washington
and writing in a sensational way about
conquering these islands in the
Caribbean and he his his his writings
were really uh belligerent and and to
say the least he was really not a very
good
publisher he sees his writings were
really like left left get the power left
let's get territories let's go for it
well David Nassau how did he influence
Congress he influenced it was he
influenced Congress
B by forcing politicians to make
decisions and to say what their opinions
were for example the Spanish Cuban
American War when the Spanish and Cubans
are fighting and he believes that
America should intervene he sends
reporters to the doorsteps of every
congressman in a Hearst district that's
in New York Chicago California all over
the place and those reporters camp on
the doorsteps until the congressman come
out and then those reporters say to the
congressman what do you think about this
this this and this they get an answer
and they publish it in the newspapers it
was impossible to stay on the fence when
Hearst wanted to get an answer for you
so get an answer from you so he again
set the agenda he was very much in favor
of intervention in America he was not in
favor necessarily of annexation of Cuba
the caller is however correct only when
it comes to in regard to Mexico
he believed one because he owned a lot
of land in Mexico that the Americans
should annex Mexico should make Mexico a
protectorate should have closer control
over went on and in Mexico and he was
influential I think in getting the
American Congress to pay attention and
to exercise whatever influence it could
over affairs in Mexico where his
reporters respected and where they will
pay they were well paid they were not
necessarily respected they were pests
they were all over the place and they
demanded answers to questions that
i politicians did not want to answer
san antonio texas good morning good
morning are you gentlemen doing this
morning good I like to present a
question to the gentleman mr. Nassau in
regards to mr. Hertz and his newspapers
the legacy that he had established that
is not being followed by that the papers
is bear his name
for instance in San Antonio mr. Hurst
had owned a science on your light news
company newspaper it was two newspapers
and it was time to express the news well
he bought the science of news and closed
out the light left us with only one
newspaper and only civil rights issues
the Hearst newspaper company has backed
away because the reason I say this is
because down here I was falsely
imprisoned and a federal judge just
session we in session bought me from
filing any papers in the federal
courthouse on took away the right to
petition the government for a writ of
habeas corpus Thank You Collin let's get
our guest David Nassau to comment on the
ownership of the different papers around
the country what is the Hearst
Corporation currently owned the Hearst
Corporation owns news pave it has moved
out of newspapers it owns a couple of
newspapers it owns a terrific newspaper
in Albany owns a newspaper in San
Francisco it owns a couple of other
dailies across the country but it's
moved very heavily it is the largest
owner of magazines across the world and
it owns a number of cable stations of
media new media companies and television
stations it has a part of A&E it is a
part of ESPN it is a huge player but not
in newspapers in the way it once was the
Hearst during his life never wanted to
let go of a newspaper even when they
were losing money in nineteen thirty
seventy you had to get rid of some
newspaper
and after his death in 1951 the company
got rid of a lot more newspapers
Burlington Vermont good morning um just
calling to say that uh I think it's kind
of hard to even put any huh I don't know
I'm just not believing the whole thing
of him being any influence maybe as an
editor but as a politician back in those
days if you were rich I think everyone
was labeled upper-class and the only way
you're going to have influence on anyone
is with money not the position you were
in I could see myself being back then
not a rich man and maybe I had view that
were stronger than mr. Hearst or anyone
at that time and I wouldn't be listened
to if I didn't have money so I think if
you had money maybe that's why you're
glorifying mr. Hearst not more for his
paper or because he was a politician
because they had money back then it was
easily easy to influence people people
with money because nobody had any what
were some of his friends and
contemporaries he did not he was I don't
know how friendly one he was with with
his contemporaries it wasn't a man who
had a lot of friends but he had a lot of
acquaintances and he was close to Louis
be mayor the publisher the I'm sorry the
movie producer he was very friendly with
Arthur Brisbane who worked for him he
was a private man he was a shy man he
spent a lot of time surrounded by people
who he didn't entirely trust because he
was so enormous ly rich and and so
enormous ly powerful and you have a
picture of him here with Louie B mayor
of course I can't find it right when I
would to find it and Winston Churchill
what what were the three of them doing
together
Churchill visited one of the things that
Hearst did I wish we had had more time
to talk about it was that Hearst wanted
and this follows up on the questions
that you were talking about in the two
hours before I came on the air first
wanted the American people to know what
was going on in Europe and he thought
the best way to do that was to not only
report on what was going on in Europe
but to have European statesmen world
statesmen
tell the American people what their
positions were unimportant matters so
Hearst hired he hired as columnist
Winston Churchill David Lloyd George
several ministers and prime ministers of
France Benito Mussolini and Adolf Hitler
Hitler Mussolini and Churchill all
worked for him Churchill visited in 1929
and this was part of it during that
visit Hearst took Winston Churchill to
the MGM studio for a big luncheon with
all the movie stars and this photograph
was taken on the steps of Marion Davies
bungalow Hearst didn't want Marion
Davies to share a dressing room with
anyone so he built her this bungalow
that was a mansion in its own right that
had a huge formal dining room and in
that dining room there was a luncheon
for Churchill at the end of the lunch
and they came out and the three of them
posed together uh Churchill was at the
time a Hearst columnist next call for
David Nassau Essex Junction Vermont good
morning good morning for much if should
be a small state but gets on here on
your program quite a bit here I have
actually two questions to ask the first
one relates to the zoo I'm curious about
it and I wonder if we could hear a
little bit about it and how it came
about what happened to it and then
secondarily if this question hasn't been
asked I wonder what he would have
thought of the treatment that the Hearst
family gave Patty Hearst I'll hang up
and let it go from there David Nassau
zoo Hearst had the largest private zoo
in the world and he had the super very
loved animals all his life he loved
animals
he loved animals so much that he forbid
anyone in San Simeon to have mousetraps
that hurt the mice the place was filled
with mice every night they would the
mice would run all over the place in the
morning they would be caught and put out
in live traps put outside of the castle
and they come back in what Hearst wanted
very much was a way to entertain his
his young Hollywood guests that were
friends of Marion Davies so as one of
the sites and the attractions at San
Simeon which was you know a half day's
journey from Hollywood he erected a zoo
and he had animals from all over the
world an extraordinary collection of
animals most of them he had to sell off
in 1937 when he went bankrupt and he
sold them to the San Diego Zoo got a lot
of those animals at the height of his
wealth how much was he worth oh gosh I
I can't even begin to try to figure it
out nor has anybody else been able to
figure it out
he not only owned all of these
newspapers but he owned mines from his
father in in Peru he had more real
estate than anybody else in New York
except maybe the the Catholic Church and
the the Queen of England millions and
millions and millions and millions
Washington DC good morning good morning
I'm concerned about the work thing
that's always concerned me the fifth six
of Buffalo Soldiers fought in the
spanish-american war they helped him in
his endeavors but yet he was racist he
never did anything to help those people
how can you set up and tell about how
great he is he's the biggest races has
ever lived was that was William Randolph
Hearst a racist we Randall purse was a
racist but his racism was more towards
people of Asian descent he was violently
anti-chinese and anti-japanese as was
every other publisher on the west coast
in terms of people of color I do not
think that it is fair to talk about him
in in quite those the terms that the
caller has uh in regard to the Japanese
however uh I mean I read many of his
commentaries in his editorials about the
Japanese and prior to World War
- and prior to Pearl Harbor and every
time I read a my you know winced with
with pain that the largest publisher on
the west coast was using these words in
these terms to characterize an important
segment of the population of California
last call for David Nassau and William
Randolph Hearst Stafford Connecticut
good morning yes I realized in the last
call just want to make wrote one real
quick comment and one quick question
it's once once asked who actually
attended the castle and it that if you
walk in Hollywood you'll know that the
people that had visited Castle but my
question was if mr. Hearst was opposed
to World War two what kind of influence
that he have on Joe Kennedy Joe Kennedy
was also opposed to the World War two
and and what kind of publishing did he
have influenced on the Kennedys coming
into power but it's a good question Joe
Kennedy was a very close friend of
Hearst Joe Kennedy was his financial
adviser in 1937 Kennedy visited Hearst
often John Kennedy got his first job
newspaper job working for there Hearst
papers the two of them were very close
they believed together that America
should not enter World War two first
reported on Kennedy's speeches Kennedy
visited Hearst and they conversed
together many times on trying to get
some unified strategy to keep America
out of the war just what to our
listeners some of the newspapers of the
Hearst Corporation still owns they
include several in Texas including the
Houston Chronicle the Lorado morning
Times Midland reporter San Antonio
express-news also the Seattle
post-intelligencer Albany Times Union
and the San Francisco Chronicle David
Nassau is the author of this book the
chief the life of William Randolph
Hearst now out in paperback thank you so
much for joining us
morning my pleasure and to